هدنه اليوم الواحد في حرب الجيش السوداني
والدعم السريع في ميزان الاختبار لعل
نتائجها تبشر بامكانيه مواصله الجهود
وصولا للسلام المفقود الذي تعثرت مختلف
جهود تحقيقه حتى الان هدوء حذر يسود
الخرطوم مع سريان الهدنه لكن مراسل
الجزيره تحدث عن اطلاق نار متقطع في
المدينه بعد سريان الهدنه لم تتحدى
التفاصيله لكن شوهد تصاعد اعمده الدخان في
سماء المدينه وقال المراسلون الطائرات
الحربيه قصفت قبل دقيقتين من سريان الهدنه
موقعا جنوبي الخرطوم بحري وان مضادات قوات
الدعم السريع الارضيه ردت عليها في هذه
الاثناء قال الرئيس مجلس السياده عبد
الفتاح البرهان خلال اتصال مع رئيس
الاتحاد الافريقي غزال عثماني ان حكومته
تساند اي حل ينهي ما وصفه بحرب الميليشيا
المتمرده الجاريه حاليا بمساعده مرتزقه
الاجانب على حد وصفه وشدد على ضروره وجود
اجهزه مراقبه فعاله لمراقبه اي وقف لاطلاق
النار مستقبلا
وعزا فشل الهدن السابقه لعدم وجود اليات
قادره وملزمه لمتابعه خروقات ميليشيا
الدعم السريع مشيرا الى عدم التزام الدعم
السريع باخلاء منازل المواطنين
والمستشفيات والمرافق العامه والمقر
الحكوميه التي تتمدرس فيها بينما شدد
الرئيس غزالي عثماني على ضروره ان يكون
احلال السلام في السودان افريقيا
حديث البرهان تزامن مع اعلان قاده الدعم
السريع مساندتهم لاي جهد لوقف اطلاق النار
لاغراض انسانيه واغاثه المواطنين وقالوا
ان على قاده الجيش النظر في معاناه
المدنيين بسبب الحرب التي يقولون ان الجيش
بقياده البرهان هو الذي اشعل فتيلها
ولطالما تحدث الطرفان واخرون عن دور
الاتحاد الافريقي في حل النزاع منفردا او
التنسيق مع المبادره السعوديه الامريكيه
المطروحه حاليا وفي كل الاحوال يبدو ان
الجميع يعولون على نتائج هدنه اليوم
الواحد هذه التي تنتهي صباح الاحد